in burkina faso's capital wagadugu
people reported hearing the sound of
heavy and sustained gunfire
[Applause]
government denials that the army has
seized control
along with reports of gun battles at
numerous army barracks all add to
growing uncertainty in a country whose
president seems conspicuous by his
absence
assurances that president rock mark
christian khabar is fine and still in
charge may not be enough to satisfy many
in a country that's seen at least half a
dozen coups or attempted coups since
independence in 1960
i strongly deny first of all the head of
state has not been detained no
institution of the country has been
threatened so as i said these movements
are localized they are circumscribed and
we're following the evolution of those
movements
security operations began in earnest a
day earlier as police clashed with
anti-government protesters who blamed
the government for failing to deal with
armed groups in burkina faso the defense
minister characterized it as putting
down an uprising
protesters say the groups affiliated
with al qaeda and isil operate in the
country with near impunity
we have seen enough we don't want the
crime we don't want the orphans we have
seen enough the president must leave he
has to leave we support the soldiers
they must resist
we've heard that the army is going to
take over and we support the army
tomorrow the day after tomorrow and even
before tomorrow we support the army
attacks in recent years have killed an
estimated 2 000 people and displaced 1.5
million
the targeting of civilians and soldiers
has also become more frequent and parts
of the country's north and east are
effectively no-go areas for government
forces
a former french colony the landlocked
west african nation is home to an
estimated 21 million people the country
is mineral rich but most work in the
agriculture sector as farmers and
herders
high rates of poverty and food
insecurity make burkina faso one of the
least developed countries in the world
green pastures for armed groups to take
root
zayn basravi al jazeera
henry wilkins is a journalist on the
ground in the capital we'll be speaking
to henry in just a few moments but first
here's one of the soldiers that henry
spoke to is taking part in that uprising
is
foreign
[Music]
that was one of the soldiers involved in
this uprising speaking to henry wilkins
who joins us now via skype from wagaduku
henry what's the situation there now
yeah it's very difficult to
get up-to-date information at the moment
the uh the government has shut down the
mobile internet
networks which means that uh the
information is really not uh traveling
at the moment certainly when i left the
the camp where the mutiny was taking
place this morning around about 10 a.m
uh the mutiny was still very much
ongoing so despite the fact that the
government does seem to be keen to
uh push the idea that everything is
under control it really doesn't seem to
be the case at the moment give us a
sense of why this is happening now henry
yeah so burkina faso has been involved
in a in a six-year conflict with armed
groups linked to islamic state and
al-qaeda
it's it's not a war that they are
winning
and then back in december in november of
last year
uh a military base in the north of the
country was overrun by terrorists um 49
military were killed and then it later
transpired that uh the military base
that was overrun hadn't been supplied
with food for two weeks so it led to
many calls from people in the general
public and within the military itself
uh for the government to
you know up its game when it comes to uh
to dealing with this um this war which
has taken over large parts of the of the
countryside
and is there any more information
at this moment as to the whereabouts of
the president
some rumors uh this morning that the
president had been
uh arrested we don't believe that these
these rumors are true certainly uh the
minister of defense went on uh on tv
this morning to deny them there hasn't
been any word from the president on
the uh the mutiny happening there has
however been a tweet
from the president around about an hour
ago giving well wishes to the national
burkinabe team competing in the afcon
football tournament but as i say nothing
from the president on
the mutiny as you said the defense
minister went on state television
earlier to say that that all was well
the fact that there hasn't been a
complete military takeover suggests
perhaps that there are elements within
the military that are still loyal
to the government
yes i don't think we're looking at a
full-scale coup at the moment it is does
seem to be an isolated uh mutiny
although the base in wagadugu the
capital is not the only one that appears
to have used the needs of there is a
base in the
north of the country as well uh were
those reports of gunfire but no it
doesn't appear to be a full-scale coup
at this stage
good to talk to you henry many thanks
indeed for being with us henry wilkins
there live in wagaduku
thank you